I think of what happened,
yes.
Today or just recently on fit with
facebook where they've,
you know,
developed a way to capitalize on the
fact that people are sharing information
with you know,
50 million people and other people who
are of a like mind and they're going to
attach at advertising to these messages.
And I think you have to be really
careful that the advertising doesn't
become so intrusive that it,
it,
it's greeted in a hostile environment.
I remember many years ago,
like the 10 or 15 years ago,
there was an idea to put advertising on
the,
um,
on the,
on the runways where the baggage was
being the baggage runways and airports
so that while you were standing there,
oh,
wondering if your baggage was actually
going to come through the door.
You could be looking at advertising on
the,
on the rubber,
on the rubber strips.
And I don't know if that was ever done.
I don't know if it was some APP,
some airports may have actually done
that.
And that was an interesting idea to try
and sell somebody something while they
were bored or,
or terrified that they'll love luggage
wasn't going to show up.
I don't know that that was ever done in
great numbers.
I certainly don't remember seeing it and
the travels I've done.
But you have to be careful when you
surround the consumer with advertising
messaging that you don't irritate them
in the process.
And that means that you have to be
entertaining,
you have to make them,
you have to be appealing,
you have to make them want to watch what
you're saying,
your messaging,
you have to be a craftsman.
So a lot of the user generated
advertising might be interesting now and
I think it's fun to think about it and,
and some of it is actually pretty good.
I think it's still an art form.
Advertising and the creative end of
advertising is still needs art artists
and craftsmen and people who are good at
storytelling and creating imagery and
making things beautiful and interesting
to watch.
So I don't know that uh,
the user generated commercials are going
to take over there.
It's kind of interesting now.
I like them.
I think it's fun,
but there's always,
it's like a mosaic,
you know?
There's a place for everything.